>> Tucker: COUNTRIES IN EUROPE
ARE SCHEDULED TO HOLD ELECTION.
AND ISLAM PARTY TO PUT SHARIA
AND TRANSFORM IN A ISLAMIC
STATE.
THE PARTY IS HOPING TO EXPAND
ITSELF SUCCESS THIS ROUND.
KITTY HAS TRAVEL TO THE TOWN,
PLACE WHERE THE PARIS TERRORIST
PLOTTED THEIR ATTACK.
AND HE INTERVIEWED THE TOWN'S
MAYOR WHO SAID THE TIES TO JIHAD
IS MARGINAL AT BEST.
>> WHERE ARE YOU GIVING THAT
INFORMATION IN OCTOBER 2016 OR
15.
>> WE HAD A LIST, BUT THIS LIST
WAS I JUST I HAD A LIST OF FEW
NAPES AND I WOULD SAY BUT IT IS
NOT THE JOB.
IT IS NOT THE JOB TO POLICE ALL
OF THOSE PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: NOT MY JOB SHE SAID.
KITTY THAT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
DID THE MAYOR SAID IT IS NOT HER
JOB TO KEEP TRACK OF THE
DANGEROUS PEOPLE.
>> SHE IS THE MAYOR OF MOLENBEEK
AND HE RAN A BAR IN THE TOWN AND
COORDINATOR OF THE PARIS ATTACK
AND 130 WERE KILLED 415 WERE
MAIMED AND WHEN I SAID TO HER,
YOU HAVE THAT LIST, YOU HAVE HIS
NAME, YOU DID NOTHING, SHE SAID,
IT IS NOT MY JOB.
IT WAS NOT MY JOB TO DO
SOMETHING AND OF COURSE, THIS IS
PART OF THE PROBLEM IN THE
JIHADI AREA OF EUROPE.
POMITITIONS ARE'VE --
POLITICIANS TURN A BLIND EYE.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE CAPTIVE TO
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE CHANGING YOUR
SOCIETY.
>> THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
I HAVE SPENT THREE DAYS WALKING
THE STREETS OF MOLENBEEK.
IT IS A 80 PERCENT MUSLIM AND A
LOT OF SUNNIS AND SHIITS AND
HARD-CORE KIND OF RELIGIOUS
INDIVIDUALS AND YOU HAVE
A PERFECT STORM MUCH A LOT OF
UNAUTHORIZED MOSQUE CONTROL
WOULD BY IRAN AND MONEY FLOWING
IN.
AND ONE TIDE OF POPULATION.
80 PERCENT HERITAGE MUSLIM AND
THEN YOU HAVE POLITICIANS AND
POLICE WHO I AM TOLD THAT ARE
HAPPY TO TURN A BLIND EYE AND
THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE PLOTTERS IN
BELGIUM.
AND THAT TERROR DRIVES TWO HOURS
AWAY TO TE DESTROY PEOPLE IN
LONDON OR PARIS.
AND RAMMA DAN IS JUST AROUND THE
CORNER.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO THE ORDINARY
BELGIANS THINK OF THIS?
>> THERE IS A GREAT DEAL OF
WHITE FLIGHT.
I THINK YOU HAVE IMAGES AND THE
MARKETPLACE, I WAS THE ONLY
WOMAN WITH MY HEAD UNCOVERED.
EVERYTHING IS COVERED WITH
A BURKA.
THEY WANT SEGATED AND SHARIA.
AND I CAN SEE IT COMING AND
THERE IS A MASSIVE WHITE FLIGHT
AND ACADEMICS AND TEACHERS AND
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS TELL ME THAT
THEY ARE UNAUTHORIZED MOSQUE AND
PEOPLE ARE MOVING OUT.
BUT IT GOES AGAINST THE LIBERAL
NARRATIVE.
BUT THESE AREAS STILL EXIST.
THERE IS A MASSIVE MOSQUE RUN BY
SOUDI WHO WAS GIVEN A 99 YEAR AS
LONG AS THEY COULD BRIEJ IN
EXTREMIST TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
MIGRANTS AND WE WONDER WHY WE
LIVE WITH THE JIHADIS NEXT DOOR.
>> Tucker: ARE THEY TEMPORARY OR
RESIDENTS?
>> THEY HAVE CITIZENSHIP.
95000 PEOPLE LIVE THERE.
85 PERCENT OF THEM ARE FRENCH
NATIONALS AND BELGIAN BORN BUT
ARE MOROCCAN.
AND THE TEACHER TODAY DIDN'T
WANT TO BE ON RECORD.
THAT NO MATTER WHAT, THREE
GENERATIONS IN NOW.
THEY HAVE ONE FOOT TILL IN
MOROCCO.
AND THAT'S THE POINT SHE SAID.
MUSLIMS TRADITIONS MATTER MORE
THAN ANY EUROPEAN HERITAGE THEY
MAY HAVE.